[Musik]
und oft und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video ja ich hoffe natürlich geht
es gut
heute steht mal wieder was an da freue
ich mich sehr drauf das habe ich
eigentlich schon letztes jahr geplant
dass man wieder zu machen oder was heißt
zu machen besser gesagt weiterzumachen
weil ich hatte so nah dass jetzt auch
schon wieder ein jahr her so eine vision
nahm ich gedacht okay wenn ich immer
meine community mit einbeziehe
es muss doch möglich sein dass man sich
so richtig heftig hoch tauschen kann
ich habe ja damals mit einer handy hülle
angefangen vielleicht jemanden ganz
kurzer ausschnitt vom video her wir sind
jetzt hier gerade auf dem weg zum
ricardo der wohnfläche marsch der welt
in köln
und ich habe gerade noch mal mit ricaner
geschrieben wer bringt auch noch seine
ganze familie wird solange wir sind
jetzt hier bei irgend so eine tankstelle
ich bin wie immer erster als hurrikan
ist noch nicht da also leute ich finde
es hier mit ricardo das ist ricardo der
heute mal tauschpartner also leute
werden jetzt hier ein mini kühlschrank
von der marke weko aber an dir denn
haben wollen schreibt über instagram und
habe dann halt das tau sechs filmen
weitergeführt ich glaube da gab es
insgesamt vier fünf teile von dann habe
ich irgendwie wieder aufgehört
im letzten teil habe ich einen
playstation controller den ich dann auch
wegen haben bekommen habe gegen diesen
mini kühlschrank getauscht stell dir
jetzt schon wirklich sehr sehr lange
steht in meiner kaffee ecke aber wenn
ich auch ganz stolz darauf den mini
kühlschrank wilden auch eigentlich nicht
geben weil er ist so geil dass ich kaufe
mir auf jeden fall 9
aber das ist jetzt sogar das letzte
produkt oder das letzte teil von dieser
reihe was ich halt hier habt und das
muss ich jetzt weiter tauschen weil ich
habe wirklich noch vor was großes am
ende zu haben so ich es wird mir diese
story dass irgendwann der nadel
angefangen hat und am ende dann haus
hatte
wer natürlich nicht schlecht dass wir so
weit kommen glaube ich es nicht aber man
kann
versuchen wir haben heute nämlich einen
termin mit dem nico nico genau und nico
haben wir bei instagram geschrieben dass
wir wieder sehr viel auf insider
geschrieben das heißt wenn du ihr auch
irgendwas hättet zum tauschen was
theoretisch den gleichen wert hat
vielleicht sogar einen höheren wert das
ist das nicht immer ganz neues für mich
oder irgendwas wie halt sagt ey ich
brauche das gar nicht mehr auch wenn das
einen coolen wert hat so ich hätte viel
lieber jetzt zum beispiel diesen mini
kühlschrank und was der nico nie
angeboten hat das sehen wir gleich da
müssen wir uns erst mal hinfahren der
wohnt ja in so einem vorort von köln
könnte man eigentlich sagen und ich muss
jetzt erstmal den mini kirchheim hier
abbauen man irgendwie bin ich ein
bisschen traurig das ist alex ganzer
stolz
ja das ist hier eine kaffee ecke wobei
diese kaffeemaschine irgendwie gerade
schaden
was da kommen wir stellen das mal kurz
nach wie das morgen ist aber ich stehe
in dieser perspektive und dann steht
alex da und schon seine milch auf jeden
morgen
ich hab' ich bin jude man erstmal solo
an aber der will das nicht
ok und das passte an diesem gerät ist
natürlich auch man kann es einmal auf
coach stellen und auf hot also man kann
theoretisch darin auch so warme getränke
aufbewahren
also das ist meistens teil neue wert 100
euro guck mal ich hab mir nach handy
wieder angefangen und bin jetzt
theoretischen bei 100 euro eigentlich
kann ich den wir noch mal kurz sauber
machen hier ja schon mache ich meine 61
stunden später was hier so ein bisschen
staub wie das eigentlich wieder aus wie
neu
da würde ich sagen ich bin bereit wir
fahren los und ich bin echt gespannt
meint auch produkt dann wirklich meinen
händen zu haben
jetzt kann es nur noch ganz vergessen zu
sagen heute alle gleich den kanal
abonnieren bald sind nur einige
millionen
aber ich freue mich schon wenn der
richtige 1 millionen steht schon geil
also ganz kurz einmal klicken klick
abonniert irgendwann später
ach so ja da sind wir in kerpen weißt du
das kennt und jetzt gehen wir zu nico
erwartet nämlich davon
köln ein händler
der film direkt ja bald
und hier in meiner wohnung weil ich
jetzt seid dabei und so dass man dem
fernseher und das jetzt 98 so jetzt habe
ich schon verraten leute weil ich wollte
einen ort stand halten
also ich hab die konfetti und
fernsehangeboten die waffen hätte ich ja
ich halte es für gut dass vom sator
sagen heißt temperaturen ist aber auch
schon etliche jahre ja aber da gibt er
funktioniert noch der funktioniert ohne
probleme sagt alles hier und so ging ich
hole eingepackt hier ist nur ein
hd-receiver digital analogie teile
schmeer und lesen und hören in dem
fernseher bedienung für kinder sie weiß
noch wie damals
und dann ist ja egal sie dann auf jeden
fall schon mal gut aus also ich glaube
das ist interessanter für viele leute
als der kühlschrank ist ja gut dass du
also ich muss sagen ich bin nicht
traurig dass sie jetzt abgeben
ich hoffe auch dass man so in eine
möglichkeit wäre auf jeden fall auch
wieder eine neue fühlt schon so ein
klein ja aber das ist schon irgendwie
cool sein zimmer zu haben oder irgendwie
passt das ist mein körper macht das
nächste an einem fernseher an staat der
einen gerade die note gut
damals etwas einer so scott cully vd
das ist ja alles muss man so standard
zwar schon alles besonders klappt das
sind 34 sollte ich kenne ich dann angst
der 52
die patientin sowieso oder gar nicht das
ist jetzt hungern koma säufer quengeln
oder ist die maxime von einer kamera ist
man ja auch ich würde sagen dann nicht
einfach mit ich hoffe also bei der
studie prof er stand bei mir oben
kleiderschrank kauft okay seit einigen
jahren setzen ja dann will man
verzichten sollte man sich irgendwie von
euch jetzt von den fernseher
interessieren
ich habe natürlich so eigentlich gedacht
dass das natürlich ziemlich leicht ist
wenn man halt so relativ viele zuschauer
hat erstmal werde ich würde das dagegen
kaufen so aber es ist gar nicht mal so
leicht muss man sagen weil viel ist
natürlich auch die meisten leute kommen
ja nicht mal eben aus der nähe zu sehen
also dass wir jetzt schon ich hätte noch
eine der harmloseren er wollte mir
irgendwie so ein huawei geben und machte
dafür aber ich weiß nicht wo das war
auch schon ein bisschen älter darf ich
jetzt wieder erstmal der fernseher
besser aber ich will den gegenwert von
euch haben möchte am besten aus der nähe
von köln und die irgendwas anderes zum
einkaufen habe dann vergaben in
servicecentern von die augen dann
stellen wir dann ins mikrofon
cool das ist nicht nur sagen ich würde
einfach alle
also vielleicht das war das so anhält
sagt dass juni du sagst ja ja
dann hatte ich am besten im kühlschrank
auf meinem den ohne das ja dann könnte
der beliebt für die zwei pferde und dann
leben wir denn jetzt mitmachen das ist
doch nicht mehr lässt sich im zimmer
stehen versteckt nicht was damit
vielleicht ja ich hoffe hier auch viel
spaß und ein kühlschrank der kommt bei
mir ins büro und dann wird macht sich
der verwaltung und wenn für schulen
zuständig und im öffentlichen dienst in
weiterstadt karten kann man auch sagen
dass du aus gärten kommst du oder hast
du keine chance haben eben gesagt wir
sind in kerpen
allein das nächste mal sollte ich kann
jetzt nicht hier im übrigen und herren
ich damals gedanken kann ja eigentlich
aufmachen verfügbar
dann haben wir uns fernseher frisch
gekocht
aber wir hatten auch einfach ihr parken
können
ich glaube schon
ich kenne diese marke divx gar nicht
kennst du das ne also nico schöne grüße
noch mal ein bisschen ein sehr netter
gedanke dass es geklappt hat und wir den
mal kurz zu hause gleich anschließend
oder das hat nämlich juli hat schon
gesagt hätte wohnzimmer gerade gar
keinen fernseher haben jetzt kurz ein
bis sich jemand meldet
und natürlich was besseres zum tauschen
hat ne also ich bin gespannt auf eure
vorschläge leute also fernsehen steht
auf jeden fall funktioniert auch alles
super ich habe jetzt gerade eben noch so
ein paar probleme mit dem receiver weil
ich da glaube ich nicht die richtigen
anschluss wird keine ahnung naja aber
das kriege ich schon irgendwie noch hin
auf jeden fall ein entfernen seit ich
gerne und ihr habt irgendwas zum weiter
tauschen dann schreibt mir auf jeden
fall bei instagram die alex ii ganz ganz
wichtig und bitte nur seriöse anfragen
am besten ist doch immer wenn ich schon
ein bisschen älter seite also ich will
jetzt niemand der zwölf jahre alt sein
neues iphone wegnehmen oder so das ist
zweimal super lieb gemeint aber auch so
was kann ich eigentlich nicht antworten
weil weil sie nicht da kenne ich habe
bestimmt noch ein problem mit euren
eltern und das wichtige ist ja auch dass
es immer ein fairer tausch bleibt also
das wirklich beide seiten zufrieden
damit sind nico zum beispiel habe ich
selber den mini kühl schon gefreut das
war es vom video ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen für weitere parks ist auf jeden
fall ein viertel nach oben da aber nicht
den kanal und wir sind uns dann morgen
um 19 uhr wieder rein
[Musik]